how is your interaction with your wife
now different because some guys in down
the street from me are married to each
other
with the legal definition of the term
marriage and those are two different
issues of course my relationship with my
wife is just as strong as it ever was so
you're saying there that that the
countless gay weddings across the
country have had no effect on the
relationship with your wife you just
said that right well it's not about the
relationship with my wife it's about the
recruiting movement of the children in
the Next Generation so that's the the
what you claim is the recruiting of
children is separate from the argument
you've made for years that gay marriage
destroys straight marriage you've just
said very clearly it's actually had no
effect
well no I didn't say it doesn't destroy
a straight marriage I think it does
destroy straight marriage it's not yours
yours yours is so good that it wasn't
able to destroy it